Eigentlich ist es unmöglich
Denn diese elemente gibt es eigentlich gar nicht trotzdem wird das periodensystem immer größer es kommen elemente dazu
Vier elemente sind erst vor kurzem dazu gekommen
Obwohl es sie auf der erde so eigentlich nicht gibt und das muss man sich mal vor augen führen sind keine moleküle
Die man mit einer chemische reaktionen erzeugen könnte, sondern eben reine atome grundbausteine weitere spannende facts
Zum thema bekommt er jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen und vielen dank auch wieder für diesen spannenden themen vorschlag
Den er mir über die messenger geschickt habt
Erst mal vielen dank an, die leute bei den messenger dort und auf unserem neuen desktop server geht so viele themenvorschläge ein
Absoluter hammer vielen dank, neu dabei im periodensystem, der elemente sind seit gut anderthalb jahren
organisch
tennessee
Nosko, wie um und leoni um ende 2016 war offiziell klar
Welche namen diese vier elemente bekommen sollten?
Denn sie werden künstlich hergestellt durch den zusammenprall von atomkernen und das auch nur in sehr kleinen mengen in der natur
Kommen sie nicht vor und auch in dem künstlichen herstellungsprozess zerfallen sie sehr schnell und jetzt mal zu den vier kandidaten
Die alle die siebte periode des systems vervollständigen starten wir mal mit dem léonie um
Nhs hat die ordnungszahl 113 und erinnert euch vielleicht aus dem chemieunterricht, dass das bedeutet
Dass es 113 protonen in seinem atom kern hat entdeckt wurde das american
Institute in japan und somit auch ist es das erste element das in asien getauft wurde
Wie horn ist eine art den namen japans in landessprache
Auszusprechen und seine bedeutung ist fast schon romantisch, es steht für das land der aufgehenden, sonne weiter geht es mit dem element
Moskwy, um mit der ordnungszahl 115 das von einem forschungsteam in der nähe von moskau entdeckt wurde er ahnt es schon daher also
Sein name genauso, wie beim element mit der ordnungszahl
117 tennessee
Ebenfalls benannt nach dem ort seiner entdeckung dem us bundesstaat tennessee
Dass ein teil des forschungsteams seinen sitz in kalifornien hat darüber können die wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen wohl hinwegsehen
Schließlich gibt es bereits ein element mit dem namen kalifornien
Wer sich von euch ein bisschen im bereich chemie auskennt kann sich vielleicht auch denken an, wen der name des elements 118
Organe von og erinnern soll und zwar an den russischen kernphysiker, juli
Organisieren, der die theoretischen grundlagen dafür gelegt hatte, dass zahlreiche sehr schwere elemente überhaupt entdeckt worden waren
Der russe ist damit übrigens erst, der zweite mensch weltweit, der noch zu lebzeiten als namensvetter für ein chemisches element
ausgewählt wurde
Verantwortlich für die namensgebung ist der chemiker verband namens international union of pure and applied chemistry
You, back, die die endgültigen namen, der vier super schweren elemente ende
2016 verkündet hatte vorher dürften die entdecker namensvorschläge machen anfang
2016 hatte die ju pack, die elemente zunächst einmal anerkannt entdeckt wurden
Die firmen nämlich übrigens schon viel früher nämlich zwischen 2002 und 2010 dazu noch ein kleiner fun fact am rande mehr als 40.000
motorrad
Fans hatten sich in einer petition dafür ausgesprochen eines der elemente nach dem verstorbenen sänger lemmy kilmister zu
Benennen lemmy um wäre dann der name des neuen elements gewesen
Die begründung lemmy war eine naturgewalt und verkörperte das wesen des heavy metal mal sehen
Vielleicht wird demnächst ein weiteres element entdeckt, dass dann nach lemmy benannt werden kann
Wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
Dann endet mich bei whatsapp und in anderen messenger nur dann verpasst er kein video denn ihr wisst
ja
Die abo box auf youtube ist ja ein bisschen
Lückenhaft über die messenger erfahrt ihr von mir auch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
Da bekommen wir auch den link zum disco server
Wo ich seit neuestem fast den ganzen tag rum menge
Einfach hier draufklicken klicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal
Klicks um social media abonnieren, da erfahrt ihr das neueste aus, der social media welt, aber nicht die
Genau glocke vergessen, und hier geht es weiter mit der faust auf klicken sex & liebe chemie, bis dann bleibt
Moment moment moment alles der reihe nach bis dann
Bleib dran